yes
um
i'm not this is not a bit
yeah not a comedy bet i'm doing
[Music]
hey what's going on and happy
thanksgiving everybody for first week
feast i'm shawn evans and you're
watching hot ones it's the show with hot
questions and even hotter wings and
today we're joined by rob lowe he's an
actor producer and director who in his
40 year long career has touched
everything from timeless films to emmy
award record-breaking tv shows he's also
releasing new podcast episodes of
literally with rob lowe as well as parks
and recollection a parks and rec recap
series alongside alan yang and don't
forget to check out 911 lone star which
returns to fox on january 3rd roblo
welcome to the show thank you i'm really
i'm very hungry
and i'm curious how are you around spicy
food i know that you like sinus clearing
salsas i do i like i like all sinus
cleaning foods um on a sweater you
should know that
it's not like a medical condition
i don't think so like if it it's it's
i'm one step away from that scene on
broadcast news
when i get really hot so that could
happen
um but
here's a little inside vegetable
we're shooting this very early in the
morning
this would for sure be the earliest i've
ever had spicy food like this for sure
[Music]
is there a referee that comes in and
goes you didn't eat enough just the
people you know just the people just the
vox popular yeah yeah exactly all right
i didn't come here oh okay
guess what
[Laughter]
guess what
that's not nothing to start with no
that's not nothing at
[Laughter]
all so between literally with rob lowe
and parks and recollection you've done a
deep dive into the world of podcasting
and i appreciate how you really know how
to give the audience what they want from
famous people talking to famous people
thank you how now that you're on the
other side of the interview table what
is your general approach to hosting
these kinds of conversations well
i grew grew up when you could go on talk
shows and they they were an exploratory
exercise right and people could crush
or they could flame out
but what they weren't were these robots
who came out publicizing the latest
marvel movie sound bite driven hack fest
which is
what that's why you're so successful and
why this world is so fun because you
can't survive
this
without revealing yourself
and so my my whole thing on my show
is
just two people talking and you forget
you're being interviewed and then the
audience feels like they've had dinner
with you and got to observe it that's my
way to do it the other thing i do is i
never ask i'm not interested in like the
obvious
stuff that they've been asked 5 000
times
there's a sweetness involved that's good
though
[Music]
i'm approaching dj khaled area i know
yeah you're flirting with the the
mendoza line the colored line here that
we have in the three spot
so in your book love life you make an
interesting point about how james
gandolfini was able to humanize a
monster in tony soprano by his use of as
you put it one of the most difficult
actor tricks of all time eating food on
camera why do you think it's important
for the audience to actually see tony
soprano wolfing down a submarine
sandwich while planning out a hit
two reasons one is you don't see it like
one of my favorite games when i watch
anything is to watch actors fake eat
like if something's boring and my wife
is watching it i don't wanna i'll
entertain myself by trying to find
actors fake eating and it happens all
the time
they'll cut to them and they'll be like
this
it'll literally look like this and
they'll be and like
you cut to me
that's the thing about it you got to
have you didn't they didn't eat
they acted like they ate
what you'd never see is this
never see it and the reason is you're
shooting the scene from 70 different
angles that if you were to do that you
would be literally ill but the other
thing is that it does humanize you it's
like there are things that we all do so
anytime you can do that the audience
relates to you
and um and he was the best his whole
character for me was predicated on just
eating like a slob and it's one of the
great great performances of all time i
think
coughs
a very jaunty chapeau yes
[Laughter]
there will be blood the movie there
might be water there will be water yeah
there will be water i'm looking forward
to it yeah so you have the privilege of
working alongside generations of
best-in-class comedy minds from lauren
michaels to farley and spade to mike and
dana to amy poehler and that's kind of
just off the top of my head right why is
your comedy north star if i pitch
something to my wife and she doesn't
like it i do it
oh yes first of all i thought you were i
thought you were just saying that i
didn't know that was a quote of mine and
i was like yes i feel exactly the same
way
like that sounds smart like i said
that's a genius my wife's comedy idiot
that's amazing how did that work out um
and by the way and i say this on my
podcast i can say anything because my
wife has no interest at all in anything
i do so like she's not gonna see this
and be mad at me how did you say that i
don't know anything about comedy it's
good to go we can just go after her um
part of it is she
loves me so much
that she doesn't want me to look like a
fool
and
if you're not willing to look like a
fool in comedy you might as well not
even bother
and like the more of an idiot that i can
look like the more i like it and
like when i did the comedy central roast
right
i went to her and said hey
they want to roast me in comedy central
this year she's like
you can't do like that you'll look like
an idiot to the nation i said honey that
that ship has sailed
but she sat there and she sucked it up
and i had the time of my life i had the
best time of my life being roasted like
i can take it i love him
well said rob are you ready to move on
here to the next wing yes los calientes
speaks for itself yes it does
literally works literally literally
this very much is like earthquakes there
you go you go
is there more is is this a big one
one of my favorite stories that i've
ever read about anyone that i'm
interviewing is when you heard that your
show the lion's den was going to get
canceled by the network you work to
rewrite the ending to be as absurd as
possible when you look back on that do
you think of it as an act of artistic
expression or an act of rebellion both
100
it
you
was
like
the show was a t i mean a good version i
thought but a very network programmer
look heroic young lawyer who's [ __ ]
the system we turned into this literal
psychopathic
murderer who'd been murdering people
secretly throughout the entire show that
you'd already watched and in the last
episode kyle chandler comes in as i'm
eating dinner and i take the steak knife
and i stab him to death open up the
window and commit suicide by jumping off
in the end of series it was like john
grisham as it started and that was
stanley kubrick as it ended
and the studio hated the show so much
they're like great sounds great like
didn't say one thing we told them
what we were going to do
um those are those those episodes never
aired right but every once in a while um
i'll get somebody from like lithuania
who'd be like my family loved stabbing
the kyle chandler that by that was the
worst lithuanian accent that's ever done
you get the point um somewhere in
eastern
eastern europe european black countries
that aired
[Music]
you did a deep dive in the book i'm very
impressed
[Music]
i don't want to jinx it
[Music]
talk about it i want you tears yeah
all right rob we have a recurring
segment on our show called explain that
graham we do a deep dive on our guest
instagram pull interesting pictures that
need more context and for you on today
the thanksgiving can i say something
your eyes are watering sir you know what
i'm not immune to it i've done this a
lot i've done this a lot but
they get to me the same way they get the
same way clean my eyes watering no not
at all
not at all what was your most memorable
run-in with wildlife while filming
holiday in the wild on location in
africa oh the the elephants we
filmed with wild african elements it's
why we went to africa we didn't want
trained elephants because kristen davis
who was my co-star is a big elephant
activist
doesn't believe in it
so
they're super dangerous
people get killed by elephants all the
time
and i can remember there's a scene where
we go take a picnic by a lake and the
elephants come out of the
out of the bush we had to wait until
they would naturally do that which we
knew it would be a certain time of day
but we had to be ready and then
we all got out of the cars and we were
the only ones
let out and everybody else had guns
and so it was surrounded by guns in case
something went wrong and it was just the
two of us as
60
elephants came out of the the brush and
you know if they charged you you gotta
hope those guys can shoot straight and
you saw the giraffes fight first day in
south africa i immediately go out on a
long run and i turned the corner and
this is what i saw i'm tired i'm sweaty
i'm running and these two
excuse me little [ __ ] are
going look at them look look
and they are
going
ham
and i never knew that giraffes fought
and i certainly didn't know that they
fought with such violence
and i ran off i was i was filming
because i it was so incredible but i was
also like dude you should just get out
are you ready to move on here this is
the uh senor lechuga here in the sixth
spot what what we've seen seen your
lechuga
yeah
yeah it's coming
clearly this is like post half time yeah
yeah
you've changed the at half time the game
plan was changed it was and now it's a
much more aggressive sort of full court
press yeah i need to adjust that
yeah
can i make the adjustment and win
so when anthony mackie was on the show
he had some thoughtful things to say
about why he believes the second and
third leads are oftentimes the best
characters which reminded me of your
quote the best part is not the biggest
but the one that's most memorable what
is it that you love about doing scenes
in which you only have one line well on
the west wing
there would be times when i would be in
a seven page scene and it would come to
the end and i would my line would be
thank you mr president
that was it
for fans of the show john spencer said
that a lot and and i always admired him
because no one could do more with thank
you mr president than john spencer he
could make
thank you mr president mean
i love you
i don't agree with you
you can make it mean i'm angry with you
he can make it mean i'm not going to do
that
and that's a very specific thing and and
i love seeing performances where actors
have one
line there's a there's one that comes
off the top of my head in glorious
bastards they execute the nazi and
writers about to execute them with the
baseball bat they go you got a medal on
you what is it for and he says valor
and they kill him he's one one line
valor crushes it
and i and i love finding those
performances
[Music]
oh boy
yeah it's
okay we're definitely in the area where
like i be these are too hot yeah
you wouldn't be both you and me both no
i'm like i might be like i'm not
i'm not eating this
[Laughter]
not for me
it's not for me
it's coming it's coming
it's in my hair
soon it will be on my forehead
and soon it'll be pouring for america to
see there will be water there will be
water
i've abandoned my water
that's a deep dive movie
is it true that the cow tipping scene in
tommyboy came about with you regaling
the movies writers with tales of that
time-honored midwestern tradition of
tipping cows 100
so i'll never forget i was playing
tennis with lauren and he said i think i
have an idea for a movie for you and
farley i was like what is it it's the
two of yous brothers
and that was it there was nothing more
and then six months later there's a
script i thought they should go cow tip
because it was midwestern i remember
that was a thing that drunk high school
people did they thought it was complete
[ __ ] they thought it was not a real
thing and people who know know it's it's
a thing
and then is there any truth to the
internet rumor that madeleine albright
once crashed the set of west wing at
three o'clock in the morning in a robe
to acosta guys
for not for being too loud and for not
having a secretary of state character
okay first of all it's conflating many
different urban legends
okay yes matt alright absolutely came to
the set
very very late we're shooting at the
kennedy center
she wanted to meet everybody
and she was sitting secretary of state
we were like
uh okay
there's that
then there is the
i was in the white house with bill
clinton and was summoned to the national
security director's office
who was a really gnarly like tough
bare knuckle dude named sandy berger
he's like sit down and i'm thinking oh
i'm [ __ ] this has got to be about like
my taxes
and he was like why is there a national
security advisor in your show
so i was like this is what this guy's
thinking
well i'm sweating i don't know if you
can see it but i'm
like you promised water and there's
water if this were a
regular show
i would be like come powder me
we can offer that rob no no i'm how
about this carpet treatment how about
this sure we're so i can see the end
zone yep i can see it yep i might eat
the whole thing
well hear that
that was amazing that was our producer
that was amazing oh my gosh
oh my god that was awesome
and now i'm rethinking it
is it time to take the jacket off
it might be jacket time
come back in
well it's all
oh bro
it's all hot sauce
that's a crazy one that's a crazy one
the [ __ ] is happening
it was like fine fine fine kill you
yeah
milk
milk's a good idea after that one
but we'll rumble we'll rumble
yeah
it can't get hotter than that yeah right
no you're right i think that that's
maximum levels that's maximum levels
how do you think that your career in
hollywood shaped you as a junior high
basketball coach
i read that you draw inspiration from
iconic sports movies like rudy to
inspire players at halftime
i'm not this is not a bit
yeah i'm not a comedy band
[Music]
is this
if
there's talking to be done
there's only
this way to do it because it's not a bit
i'm honestly not doing that
i i think that hot uh
okay
i i think that uh sports a halftime
speeches
[Music]
are
the amount of water coming off me yeah
are are
like
a part of acting's mount rushmore
there's kurt russell and miracle there's
who's yours there's rudy
i was a coach for my son's teams and i
was very much like always trying to give
them the rah-rah speeches like that they
were too young to care they were not
interested this is hot
[Music]
we're almost ready to go to the next one
because it can't get any worse right can
it that's true and and you've you've
tour it's scorched earth in your mouth
you know so
it's impossible what's amazing is it
keeps coming in waves yeah
like first it blisters
your tongue
then it closes up your throat
then your eyeballs pop out
and and then your tears ejaculate
that's a good way of putting it i'll
keep an eye out on this side of the
table
it is unbelievable okay
okay i think we can go to the next one
all right this next one is hellfire's
cranked
we are almost to the finish line
wait a minute yeah
[Music]
oh
[Music]
dude took two bites there you go don't
say that i was trying to
play
and maybe after the last one a little
bit
[Music]
but you gotta chill you just gotta chill
zen out
you gotta chill you gotta just gotta
relax
feel the vibe
relax the spice
mind over me i see you
rip
coverage and drip
so i know that sasquatch has long been a
topic of fascination for you ever since
you saw the legend of boggy creek as a
child and then in 2017 with your sons
matthew and john owen you did the low
files for a e where you continued to
hunt for bigfoot and other sorts of
unsolved curiosities when you go on an
adventure to find bigfoot do you rely on
resources or maps of any kind or is it
one of those things where you just pack
some supplies and walk out into the
woods oh no you gotta know where you
can't just you have to fish for the fish
are and my thing is i don't know if any
of it is real or not but
i will say that being curious about it
and believe in and it makes it more fun
like i i don't want to be shut off to
that like dude
scooby doo
and anthony bourne parts unknown are my
two favorite shows ever so the low files
was that show in a blender right it was
literally us going to places eating
stupid food and looking for
creatures and the fact that a e
bankrolled it
was one of the great great things i
could have done it for a hundred years
well what a win in your career
yes uh-oh what's happening you're
shaking something that can't be good
[Music]
i'm competitive
so i'm gonna do it
it's chemicals there's not even
chemicals in here right right
open it's like acid yeah
this whole back half it accelerates
quickly
look at how slow that i'm gonna do this
like i'm gonna do it but i'm not stupid
yeah
[Music]
there we go
that's plenty that's plenty that's
plenty
it's on there technically i did it it's
on there i'm trying to get as much off
as i can
cheers rob cheers what a ride this is
amazing
i'm going down
oh bro
i know going through it going through it
i'm getting down into my gizzard
as quickly as i can well you know what
speaking of gizzards rob lowe we are
closing out yet another hot ones
thanksgiving special and the only way to
truly put a bow on this thing is to hit
you with a quick guide to celebrating
according to rob lowe oh please
pumpkin pie apple pie pecan pie or some
other kind of pie all of them
all of them big pockets sophie's choice
i can't choose between those pies
they're all good
what's the most overrated side dish i
don't think that's not even a question
it's um
uh yams
candy dams and sweet potatoes and then
finally what's the best vintage roblo
after school special to watch with the
family after the cowboys game is over oh
for sure
it's the most evocative dramatic and
well-thought-out titles in the history
of television movies
schoolboy father
[Laughter]
what i like about it is there's no doubt
what it's about like dishwasher you know
it's it's right in the name it's right
there you is it i'm a boy i'm still in
school
i'm also become a father
well you know what i would cheers to
that and look at you rob lowe taken on
the wings of death there was water but
there was also glory as you finished all
10 wings and now there's nothing left to
do but roll out the red carpet for you
this camera this camera this camera let
the people know what you have going on
in your life ah
well um i don't sweat when i do my new
podcasts uh literally if you like this
at all you're gonna love literally um
every interesting big star on it and if
you love parks and recreation you're
gonna love parks and recollection where
we take every episode and pull the hood
up and find out how we did it and um
download now
great job thanks man
i did it
[Applause]
but it's
dude it's happening
you broke down the fourth wall it's
early do you have a busy day
you so get this
pardon my take oh really uh a tell us a
big cat i said a youth conference
and two scenes on my show
but other than that it's an easy day
[Laughter]
the [ __ ] is happening
hey what's going on hot ones fans this
is sean evans checking in with a very
exciting announcement you know after 16
seasons i'd like to think that we
perfected the hot sauce symphony and now
i gotta hand it to us
we've perfected the packaging it's the
custom-made hot ones official 10-pack
briefcase now available at heatness.com
take a look inside it's so pretty and
the perfect gift for the spice lord in
your life just get some friends make
some wings bring some ice cream and be
careful around the eyes heatness.com
heatness.com to get your hands on the
custom-made hot ones official 10-pack
briefcase
i know i love it
[Music]